[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
la lutte qui se fait chaque jour plus
féroce sur les marchés financiers
internationaux représentent un danger
pour nos entreprises françaises la
banque publique d'investissement dont le
travail en faveur de l'économie
française est à saluer vient de mettre
en place un fonds d'investissement
français dont l'objectif est justement
de renforcer l'arsenal de la france pour
protéger ses fleurons face à l'appétit
de fonds internationaux aux moyens
financiers colossaux le lac d'argent ce
nouveau fonds d'investissement dont vous
êtes l'instigateur est un projet louable
pour protéger des entreprises françaises
alors qu'il doit atteindre 10 milliards
d'euros par la suite vous ambitionnez de
réunis à 4 milliards d'euros dès le mois
d'avril
mais voilà qu'après avoir vu que les
premiers milliards d'euros ont été levés
auprès d'assureurs d'entreprises ou de
familles françaises ce qui est une bonne
chose je tiens à le dire
nous apprenons que le lac d'argent sera
alimenté à hauteur de 25% par un fonds
souverain émirati mubadala même si cet
investissement étranger auprès de bpi
france contribuera au projet de défense
de nos fleurons
il soulève d1 - certains doutent que
j'aimerais voir éclaircie tout d'abord
madame le ministre
pouvez vous nous indiquer quelles sont
les garanties que vous allez fixée
concernant premièrement la provenance
des fonds mais également concernant le
pourcentage maximum des actifs étrangers
dans le lac d'argent
plus précisément pouvez-vous nous
assurer que les capitaux français
demeurent majoritaires dans ce fonds et
si ce n'est pas le cas que bpi gardeur à
la main quelle que soit la composition
du fonds enfin ne serait-il pas
judicieux d'ouvrir ce fonds
d'investissement aux petits épargnants
français en toute transparence par
quelque support que ce soit